I have news on the Democratic side from
Massachusetts and here in Massachusetts
Louis is it fair to say that Hillary
Clinton this is this is widely
considered a Hillary Clinton stronghold
the Clintons have a long history here
she's been the favorite for a while is
that fair I think that's fair to say
yeah the Clintons are popular here
there's a new poll from PPP which shows
Bernie Sanders actually surpassing
Hillary Clinton here in Massachusetts on
the Democratic primary side now leading
hillary clinton 49 to 42 with a margin
of error of about four point two percent
now this is particularly notable not
only because it's Massachusetts and
Hillary Clinton has been the presumptive
frontrunner here for a very long time in
this Democratic primary but it's
particularly notable because PPP is
generally a democratic establishment
pollster that always seems to favor
Hillary when we looked at the Iowa
polling just before the Iowa caucuses
PPP was the poll that gave Hillary the
highest level of support let's compare
this recent Massachusetts primary poll
to prior polls in Massachusetts you will
see reading from the bottom to the top
if you're reading along with me in
October there was an emerson college
poll this at Hillary Clinton at 59 and
Bernie Sanders at 25 this was a 34-point
advantage for Hillary Clinton one month
later roughly in November of 2015 the
boston globe in conjunction with Suffolk
University had another poll and Hillary
Clinton's lead shrank from 34 to 25 and
now three months on after we've seen the
results from Iowa after we've seen the
results from New Hampshire PPP the
typical Democratic establishment poll as
Hillary Clinton down by seven percentage
points can do you believe this Louis can
it be believed I believe it but before
you comment this is such a UH a Hillary
Clinton stronghold that in 2008 even
though Barack Obama was the eventual
Democratic nominee Hillary Clinton
defeated Barack Obama here in the
Massachusetts primary by 16 points no
less so this if true would have huge
implications yes but I believe this
because the social media storm yay
around Bernie and Hillary as I think
I don't even know if it's reached its
peak right but it's it's at a seriously
high level right now for a guy who hates
Twitter and Instagram you seem to be
putting a lot of weight behind the
social media presence of Bernie Sanders
I think this is a big part of the reason
he's doing so well I think this is big
part of the reason he's gained so much
weight on that of course uh a good
performance in both Iowa New Hampshire
will you be voting on march first in the
Massachusetts primary first I have to
register okay well if you don't register
here you could always vote in in like
western mass you'd have to just get a UH
absentee ballot right yeah but I'd like
to do it here there and I'm sensing a
little bit of weakness on these answers
from Louis on this voting issue but uh
will I mean your vote really could
actually matter I mean we have it's
closed in on where yeah normal yeah
start emailing ladies and gentleman
please cuz you know what happens when
people don't email telling Lois to vote
as a side note Bernie Sanders is
reportedly uh ahead of Hillary Clinton
by something like 70 points in his home
state of Vermont I guess that's not too
surprising Louis it is his home state he
reportedly has eighty-six percent
support there yet not surprising I
predict that that but that might even go
up the online news world is getting
pretty cluttered with lots of nonsense
there's the so-called news sites that
rewrite news articles and then there's
the website we all know that we just
can't trust so lately i've been reading
smashpipe which is an online magazine
whose goal is to surprise amuse and tell
readers things they don't already know
on a wide range of topics in current
events and culture smashpipe is less
interested in trending topics than in
what's actually going on and smashpipe
has no ads whatsoever other than the
reader generated classified-ad section
and they never will smashpipe is what
happens when you on a bad day stub your
toe on the miseries and mysteries of
life check it out at